bonjour à tous bienvenue aussi aux
téléspectateurs de public sénat pour
cette émission consacrée aux ateliers
des départements on sait que des
élections importantes auront lieu les 20
et 27 juin qui concerneront évidemment
les départements français mais aussi les
régions les enjeux dans ces territoires
dans les départements sont extrêmement
forts et on sait on le verra dans cette
émission quel rôle les départements ont
joué notamment dans la crise sanitaire
et dans la façon dont ils ont
territorialisée leurs mesures pour être
au plus près des populations
je suis très heureux d'accueillir dans
cette émission dominique bussereau le
président de l'assemblée des
départements de france également
président du département de la charente
maritime et ancien ministre bien sûr
monsieur bussereau
bonjour soyez le bienvenu j'accueille
également jean-luc claeys qui est le
président du conseil départemental de la
gironde j'espère que vous m'entendez
bien et qu on vous entendra également
monsieur le président claeys soyez le
bienvenu merci
et puis et puis troisième invité
françois sauvadet le président du
conseil départemental de la côte-d'or
ancien ministre également cher françois
bien le bonjour à vous bonjour alors on
va parler des départements évidemment
des enjeux notamment en matière de crise
sanitaire mais aussi toute l'actualité
autour des départements la
décentralisation avantages inconvénients
mais pour bien planter notre décor je
suis très heureux également d'accueillir
sur ce plateau jérôme fourquet qui est
le directeur opinion de l'ifop un
sondeur très connu s'il en faut bonjour
alors on va cadrer ce débat cette
émission avec cette étude que l'ifop a
réalisé pour cette émission sur les
ateliers des départements avec des
conseils départementaux et c'est ça qui
m'a le plus frappé dans votre étude
jérôme qui sont finalement très fier et
très attaché aux mandats qu'ils exercent
oui tout à fait donc c'est cette enquête
qui a été réalisée par l'ifop à la
demande de l'assemblée des départements
de france étude inédite puisqu'elle
l'interrogé pas le grand public mais les
conseillers départementaux
eux-mêmes et 658 d'entre eux sur les
4000 que nous comptons en france ont
accepté de se prêter au jeu de répondre
à nos questions le premier enseignement
farce et que 93 % d'entre eux se disent
satisfaits d'exercer leur mandat et plus
de 6,6 sur dix d'entre eux sont même
très satisfait de le faire donc c'est un
niveau de satisfaction qui est très
élevé il n'y a pas de blouse de l'élu
chez les conseillers départementaux
alors il faut qu'il n'y a pas de blouse
de lenny quand on parle des conseillers
départementaux et ça c'est très
important ce qui est pas le cas mais je
vais pas vous demandez vous êtes tombé
dessus
quand on parle avec des maires eux
parfois ils ont un peu le blues mes
conseils départementaux non non parce
que sans doute ils sont peut-être moins
en première ligne que les maires
notamment dans les petites communes et
puis ils ont on le voit dans l' enquête
des sources de satisfaction qui sont
très importantes
au premier rang desquels la capacité à
porter à faire advenir des projets
localement leurs capacités aussi
entretenir des relations avec la
population ce qui nourrit très fortement
leur satisfaction et deux tiers d'entre
eux trouvent qu'il est facile
relativement facile d'exercer leurs
fonctions alors jérôme
j'aimerais juste parce que je veux qu'on
fasse ce teasing important sur l'étude
de l'ifop a consacré le territoire et je
leur ai donné juste la parole évidemment
à 2000 bussereau le président de
l'assemblée des départements de france
pour qu'ils cadrent un peu cette
émission et ses attentes
et puis rappelez aussi jérôme fourquet
cheval oublier qu'en 2019 vous avez été
prix littéraire de l'assemblée des
départements de france prix lamartine et
fille que vous êtes l'homme évidemment
de l'archipel français qui avait bien
sérier les problèmes et l'importance des
territoires et et des départements
président bussereau vous avez la parole
si beaucoup merci à vous et eric revel
baisse
dition merci à jérôme et nous faire part
de résultats de cette enquête qui sont
pas intéressants pourquoi cette
rencontre aujourd'hui par les moyens
numériques a d'abord une raison
malheureuse fut l'est certains sans
sanitaires
nous devrions en ce moment même tenir
notre congrès annuel à la rochelle il
aurait déjà eu lieu avoir lieu au mois
de novembre effet nous sommes obligés
malheureusement de de le faire
simplement en numérique par cette
expression politique est ce qu'on peut
dire aujourd'hui soit des départements
d'abord comme vous l'avez rappelé son
élection mme a dû se battre pour que ces
élections aient lieu et avec nos
collègues des territoires unis les
maires de france les régions nous avons
insisté auprès du gouvernement pour que
les échéances soient respectés et
maintenant quelle leçon pour que ces
élections puissent se dérouler dans de
bonnes conditions
il faut que dès que ce sera possible on
puisse tenir des réunions qui ont eu
pour les départementales sont pas des
meetings avec des milliers de personnes
il faut que les candidats puissent se
déplacer il faut que les candidats
puissent faire connaître le programme
bref il faut que ce soit des élections
véritablement démocratiques et
républicaines et ça nous y employons
auprès du gouvernement en agissant en ce
sens ensuite vous l'avez évoqué cette
période très particulière sanitaires
nous avons été boulot si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi dès le début de la
crise au moment où il n'avait pas de
masque
au moment où tout allait mal et la
souplesse d'action du département avec
nos pompiers et nos équipes a permis
d'être de bons relais sur le terrain
dede de nos collègues des communes est
véritablement d'agir même si ça nous a
coûté beaucoup d'argent et c'était notre
mission de solidarité sociale et
solidarité territoriale
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans la
vaccination à présent la république à
s'exprimer vendredi on verra bien ce qui
nous dit nous continuons d'insister pour
que cette vaccination
d'abord il y eu et qu'il y ait
suffisamment de vaccins pour tout le
monde
le plus rapidement possible et puis
peut-être un peu moins de vaccinodromes
même si c'est pas une intéressant est
beaucoup plus de proximité dans la
ruralité sur tous les territoires que
tous nos concitoyens se fasse ce taxi de
quoi parlons nous actuellement avec que
l'état avec le gouvernement en dehors de
ces demandes étaient de campagne
chaque année au département parlons
beaucoup d'action sociale les services à
domicile on s'est aperçu de leur
importance très grande pendant la crise
l'an passé et encore aujourd'hui nous
avons exercé des primes plupart des
départements à un tout leur personnel
aujourd'hui le gouvernement voudrait
n'est pas absurde
augmenter les salaires des personnels
des sommes tous d'accord à
condition que cette augmentation ne soit
pas imposé et à condition qu au
gouvernement il participe pour l'instant
il donne des chiffres qui sont un peu
pharmaceutique petit flacon et nous
voudrions que le gouvernement soit du
côté dans cette revalorisation que nous
ne contestons pas sur le massif et puis
nous savons dans des problèmes avec
l'aide à l'enfance on voit bien que
beaucoup de familles se sont désagrégées
pendant cette crise on n'a jamais autant
d'enfants ils nous sont confiés des
travailleurs sociaux qui font un très
gros travail qui sont parfois
injustement attaqué jean luc gleyze en
gironde en sait quelque chose tout comme
françois sauvadet en côte d'or et nous
souhaitons continuer cette action et
l'améliorer nous avons même demandé dans
lequel les futurs décentralisation à
prendre la responsabilité des bêtises
colère qui nous permettrait avec mes 5
pmi avec l'aide sociale à l'enfance
d'avoir une action encore plus visible
dans le secteur de l'enfance et de
pallier certaines absences de l'état
tout ça évidemment un coût les
départements ne sont plus maîtres
malheureusement leur fiscalité nous a
enlevé contre votre gré notre part de
l'impôt foncier est donc aujourd'hui
nous dépendons des droits de mutation
qui sont liées à la situation
immobilière de chaque département
c'est plus facile en gironde aux gens
arrêtés nous porte de l'atlantique que
dans la nièvre corrèze où entre eux donc
ces ressources ont continué à progresser
l'an passé malgré la crise mais nous en
sommes dépendants au moment les
fermetures de commerces et magasins
certainement entraîner des bisous
chômage d'entreprise aussi et nous
craignons au printemps dans quelques
mois
un grand nombre de bénéficiaires du rsa
supplémentaires donc nous devons à se
révéler d'où des membres très claire de
l'adf des départements de france au
gouvernement d'abord continuer à nous
aider à assurer une bonne péréquation de
ces de ses droits de mutation pour que
les départements les plus favorisées
puisque aider ceux qui le sont moins que
nous ayons à nouveau un levier fiscal
que
puissions selon qu'on pense était
beaucoup mieux sur des récemment versons
la moitié personnes la totalité les
panneaux en bourse que la moitié ça
devrait être la totalité et que sur le
douloureux 12 pieds évidemment
accompagnés également les compensations
de l'état soit beaucoup plus importante
car en réalité sont une conséquence de
la politique de l'immigration qui par
nature il est politique légal voilà un
peu les sujets de vos parents en dernier
mot peut-être sur la relance
nous nous partageons la volonté des uns
des autres
bien sûr d'augmenter dl les entreprises
en cas de la relance les départements
malheureusement n'ont plus de levier
explique onomique le site à venir
matière touristique agricole la pêche et
la conchyliculture la forêt l'an passé
par suffisant donc nous avons pâti des
contrats de relance avec l'état beaucoup
de départements en raison de signes et
sonata encore le département de la
vienne en acier 1 pour que nous
puissions participer à la relance et aux
côtés des communes et de l'étal
puissions participer à ces fameux
contrats crt eux c'est ces contrats qui
sont faits au niveau les intercomités en
un mot et en conclusion et jérôme
fourquet le voit bien dans son enquête
si ceux qui nous écoutent se demande ce
que font des parois de faisons deux
choses la solidarité territoriale et la
sécurité sociale nous sommes le relier
les communes nous sommes souvent le
banquier des petites communes qui n'ont
pas d'autres moyens d'accéder à
l'investissement nous travaillons bien
sûr en bonne intelligence avec les
régions ne sont pas si bons aussi
souvent en financement qui ferroviaire
alors que c'est une compétence des
régions et nous souhaitons 1 et n'a pas
pas moins centralisée le gouvernement
prépare
il doit peut-être des il a repris en
quatre desserts décentralisation
différenciation s'est il a repris un
certain nombre de nos demandes mais trop
peu et je regrette que ce quinquennat
qui s'achèvera l'an prochain n'est pas
été l'occasion de grands
période de décentralisation et celle
engagée sous l'autorité de françois
mitterrand parole pierre mauroy et
qu'elle soit de faire ce l'autorité de
jacques chirac jean pierre raffarin
véritablement si on veut une france
mieux gérer plus - imposer plus proche
des réalités il faut aller plus loin
dans la décentralisation
cb stage nous avons porté d un réseau
durant cette campagne électorale
est ce le message que l'adf a porté
pendant toutes ces années dans cette
mandature et que naturellement nous
continuerons à porter après les
élections des 20 et 27 juin merci
beaucoup président bussereau d'avoir
cadrer cette émission alors deux
chiffres jérôme fourquet qui à mon avis
illustre bien ce que vient de dire
dominique bussereau solidarité sociale
dans un pays qui est qui est exemple
solidarité financière aussi avec les
entreprises c'est un rôle important des
départements mais aussi question sur la
décentralisation deux chiffres et
j'aimerais que voulait comme entier 86%
des conseillers départementaux estimé
est perçue comme très proche de leur
territoire ça tombe bien parce que c'est
lui qui incarne le lien social dans
cette crise sanitaire
et puis ce ratio sept sondés sur dix
jugent négativement la politique de
décentralisation actuelle oui tout à
fait donc ça ça fait écho à ce que
disait le président bussereau
le on peut penser que la crise du coc
vie dont on peut pas analyser la crise
du coc vite comme un gigantesque crash
test auquel a été soumis l'appareil
d'état central est pour beaucoup de
français ils se sont rendus compte qu'il
y avait des failles que on avait des
retards à l'allumage et beaucoup ont
constaté que les départements les
mairies les régions avaient été les
acteurs de proximité qui avait permis
notamment dans la phase 1 de confinement
et bien d'approvisionner la population
en masque de assurer la circulation de
l'information de donner un coup de main
à tel ou tel centre hospitalier de
mobiliser les pompiers localement etc
etc alors que les antennes de la scion
nationaux de l'appareil d'état national
était beaucoup plus lent à se mettre en
branle à c'est ce que nous on voit dans
d'autres enquêtes là non pas auprès des
conseillers départementaux mais auprès
du grand public donc il ya ce
jugement-là qui s'est renforcée cet
appel qui vient du terrain davantage de
décentralisation qui est bien évidemment
souhaité par les élus locaux mais qui
rejoint les préoccupations de la
population et notamment décentralisation
qui serait à mettre au service de
davantage de solidarité et davantage de
protection de bouclier social
cette question sept sondés sur dix dans
votre sondage ifop jugé négativement la
politique de décentralisation de la
france je poserai bien sûr la question
tout à l'heure à jean luc claisse le
président de gironde et à françois
sauvadet des parts président du conseil
départemental la côte d'or mais il le
juge comment négativement
ils ont l'impression qu'on leur a refilé
la patate chaude passez moi l'expression
sans qu'ils aient les moyens de
l'exercer
ou bien ce qu'ils considèrent que c'est
trop lourd à gérer alors je je pense que
c'est d'assez la première hypothèse qui
est la bonne c'est à dire et le
président bussereau l'a rappelé donne
des compétences sans forcément
transmettre
octroyer tous les financements qui
permettent d'assurer cela et puis si on
revient l'expérience du coc vide on a
aussi sans doute une très forte
insatisfaction concernant le cadre
réglementaire et là on a bien vu c'est à
dire que l'état central n'a pas favorisé
les initiatives individuelles et à +
s'est plutôt distingué par sa capacité à
empêcher les initiatives plutôt que les
accompagner alors c'était pas en
l'espèce des présidents de conseils
départementaux mais des présidents de
conseils régionaux qui avait fait venir
à leurs frais des cargaisons de masse
qui on se souvient de cette image de
préfet accompagné par la maréchaussée
qui arrivait sur les tarmacs des
aéroports pour saisir les cargaisons
c'est à dire le symbole c'était le
représentant de la république il est à
centrale paris qui disait vous êtes
débrouillez vous avez été prise avec
nous et donc il ya à la fois un problème
ancien c'est à dire chargé de voir qui
est qui qui pose problème
et aussi ce cadre réglementaire et aussi
sans doute cette relation c'est à dire
est-ce qu'on est dans une relation de
confiance entre l'état central et l'élu
ou est-ce qu'on est toujours et encore
il ya un vieux sur moi jacobins en
france sur un contrôle
c'est à dire on va regarder ce qui s'est
passé au moment de la sortie du premier
confinement dans les écoles avec ce
manuel de déconfinement de 69 pages qui
va travailler dans toutes les communes
et les élus locaux d écouter on vous a
pas attendu on s'est débrouillé tout
seul
la seule chose que vous êtes capable de
faire c'est de nous mettre des bâtons
dans les roues du contrôle tatillon donc
jérôme fourquet
votre étude illustre bien le lien très
de proximité entre les conseils et
conseillers départementaux et le lien
social et la solidarité dont on a besoin
plus qu'avant avec cette crise sanitaire
votre sondage illustre bien également la
défiance vis-à-vis de cette
décentralisation sans moyens et
finalement il nous faut est ce qu'il
faut retenir d'autres chiffres alors on
a un deuxième volet de cette enquête qui
est qui est très intéressant qui
consiste à faire un premier bilan de la
réforme du mode d'élection des
conseillers départementaux puisque
nos auditeurs le savent on est passé de
scrutin uninominal à un binôme paritaire
hommes-femmes qui a été élue parmi nos
conseillers départementaux qui affiche
devant au moins deux mandats c'est à
dire qu'ils ont été élus une au moins
deux premières fois dans l'ancien
système et bien six sur dix d'entre eux
estiment que cette réforme a changé leur
travail au quotidien
mais quand on regarde dans le détail la
même proportion estime que la mise en
place de ces binômes est plutôt une
bonne chose
un doc on a un premier retour
d'expérience qui est positif sur une
réforme qui a quand même énormément
modifier les choses on rappelle
redécoupage de la carte cantonale on est
passé de 4000 à 2000 quand on mise en
place du binôme donc c'est quand même
une révolution vis-à-vis d'une vieille
institution comme le le conseil général
et le canton et parmi ceux qui ont vécu
les deux systèmes
eh bien il n'y a ni un jugement qui aux
deux tiers est positif mais ça a changé
un peu le profil j'allais dire culturel
de cette politique ancrée dans le
territoire parce qu'avant c'est plutôt
parler du conseil du conseiller général
vont avant c'était plutôt une élection
un peu de notables des gens qu'on
connaissait
est ce que le binôme avec tout les
avantages que ça représente notamment
pour la parité n'a pas un peu modifié ce
profil politique avait bien sûr donc
déjà on a une parité stricte maintenant
par la force des choses on est à 50 50
en répartition hommes-femmes ce qui
change beaucoup de choses alors les
vieilles habitudes ou les vieilles les
vieux imaginaires ont la vie dure à
parce que quand on regarde les réponses
de nos interviewés hommes et femmes sur
les commissions dans lesquelles il siège
on s'aperçoit que comme on dit à
sciences po aujourd'hui les choses sont
très genre et c'est à dire que sur la
route les finances c'est encore très
masculin et sur la jeunesse l'action
sociale c'est plus féminin néanmoins on
a effectivement une diversification des
profils et c'est sans doute une bonne
chose alors autre élément qui nous
permet de dire que la greffe a
fonctionné que la greffe a pris parmi on
le verra tout à l'heure les conseillers
départementaux très nombreux qui
souhaite se représenter lors des
prochaines élections départementales
sept sur dix d'entre eux disent on le
fera avec le même binôme donc ça veut
dire que le l'attelage a tenu et que
cette voie là cette innovation a donné
un certain nombre de résultats positifs
ils ont aussi sans doute qu'il nous le
dise davantage de temps pour porter
traiter un certain nombre de dossiers
parce que vous êtes deux pour vous
occuper d'un mandat leur certes souvent
avec des cantons dans le périmètre
la surface géographique a été étendue
mais il ya un partage des rôles qui
s'est manifestement progressivement qu'à
l'est d'autres commentaires d'autres
chiffres alors on peut aller sur un
troisième un troisième sujet qu'on a on
a commencé à aborder sur l'intention
pour ses conseillers départementaux de
se représenter 81 % d'entre eux ont
l'intention de rempiler
si vous me permettez l'expression donc
c'est beaucoup et on le voit sur la la
diapositive on en a même si sur 10 on
était allé qu'il enquête a été réalisée
en octobre dernier il y en a même si sur
dix d'entre eux qui sont certains de
vouloir se représenter quand on regarde
dans le détail des choses
l'intention de se représenter
logiquement un peu plus forte parmi les
conseillers départementaux qui
appartiennent aux majorités
départementales puisqu'ils ont été en
capacité sans doute financièrement de
porter davantage de projets leur mandat
était plus exaltant que si on était dans
l'opposition mais on rappelle que quand
on l'ifop par exemple sont des les
maires un an avant les municipales
on n'avait que six maires sur dix qui
comptait se représenter c'est pour ça
que j'ai fait du mal à parler à la
raison entre les conseillers l'épave à
la hâte et donc là on voit que ce ce
public-là est à l'aise dans son mandat
et à l'intention de se représenter très
massivement alors même encore une fois
qu'il eut cette réforme avec ces binômes
quand pour aller dans le sens de ce que
disait le président bussereau quand on
les interroge sur quels seraient les
services publics de proximité
les a développées dans leur département
les priorités sont assez net services
pour les personnes âgées dépendantes
donc on voit que c'est quand même le
gros sujet qu'ils ont à l'esprit
toujours et encore la question des
réseaux de transport et de circulation
également
les établissements scolaires et l'aide
au développement économique et à la
formation de lumière retenir que même si
le président bussereau a parlé à juste
titre de tout ce qui se passe autour des
mineurs non accompagnés
on a un sujet majeur k qui identifiait
comme tel par nos conseillers
départementaux c'est comment on prépare
la révolution du quatrième âge la
dépendance parce que encore une fois
c'est le département qui est souvent en
première ligne sur cette thématique là
merci beaucoup jérôme fourquet
j'aimerais entendre maintenant les
commentaires les analyses les réflexions
de nos présidents de départements
jean-luc l'aise depuis la gironde le
président à bussereau parlait de
solidarité vous avez vu parmi les
principaux items souhaité il ya cette
aide aux personnes âgées notamment on
est vraiment dans cet espace dans cette
sphère de solidarité qu incarne bien
finalement un département oui je crois
que les solidarités qui font qu'ils sont
le coeur de mission la fibre même des
départements parle plus que j'avais un
nos concitoyens et concitoyennes parce
que là la crise sanitaire a amené à
considérer que dans les moments de
difficulté de crise ce que l'on
recherchait c'était des actions de
protection les actions d'accompagnement
et donc des actions de solidarité
parfois la solidarité s'est exprimé de
façon citoyenne vers votre moment ce
sont les départements qui la porte de
plein droit et qui sont capables de
l'exercer en toute proximité pense qu'il
faut jamais oublier que le département
c'est le quotidien avant tout de 16
essais auxquels nous adressant souvent
nous ne sommes pas tout à fait visible
dans l'action publique que nous avons
parce qu'elle est un peu diffusés
qu'elle est très individuelle si on
prend l'exemple de l'aide personnalisée
à l'autonomie pour les personnes âgées
et bien c'est un versement qui est opéré
auprès des personnes de façon
individuelle qui n'est pas forcément un
grand geste architectural bâtiment qu on
pourrait construire même s'il vous
arrive de construire des collèges et
donc c'est ce ce quotidien très faim que
nous que nous réalisons au travers de
nos politiques publiques et qui sont
finalement inquiète très attendu par nos
concitoyens particulièrement aussitôt en
situation de crise mais je pense que
l'intérêt ce passage de la crise
qu'ovide aura été sans doute de
donner à voir spécifiquement encore le
département auprès des services à
domicile auprès des personnes
handicapées au travers du service
départemental incendie de secours et
puis dans ce qu évoqué dominicus heureux
tout à l'heure sur des actions très
concrètes sur la fourniture des masques
sur l'aide pour les ter et teoz et
vaccine us pour la vaccination
eh bien nous sommes là en réactivité en
proximité et qu'il ya des difficultés et
de façon plus générale ou le quotidien
courant de toutes les personnes qui nous
adressons merci jean luc l'aise
peut-être un mot et jérôme fourquet
avant je donne la parole à françois
sauvadet est ce qu'on pourra dire est-ce
qu'on peut d'ores et déjà dire que cette
crise sanitaire du violente en france
comme ailleurs
finalement aura renforcer ce lien de
proximité entre les citoyens et leurs
conseils départementaux
alors entre avec les conseils
départementaux sans doute qui est sûr
c'est en tout cas avec les collectivités
locales
d'une manière générale avec une opinion
publique qui souvent résonne un peu de
manière binaire entre l'état central et
collectivités locales est clairement ce
sont les collectivités locales qui ont
entre guillemets marqué des points dans
cette crise sanitaire avec une une
insatisfaction et une pointe de défiance
vis-à-vis des services centraux de
l'état même si les hôpitaux ont répondu
présent mais les collectivités locales
ont montré par leur agilité et leur
proximité qu'elle était capable de
répondre présent dans des crises aussi
grave que celle que nous avons traversée
françois sauvadet président du conseil
départemental de la côte-d'or peut-être
aussi
essentiellement vos réactions après ces
quelques chiffres 1 tiret de cette étude
importante de l'ifop réalisée par jérôme
fourquet ses équipes
d'abord bon moi je vois je vois que vous
avez tout résumé en deux mots le premier
ce qui intéresse les conseillers
départementaux c'est la capacité à agir
au quotidien et ça ça se retrouve dans
le leurre leur volonté de poursuivre
leur mandat et puis le deuxième message
qui s'adresse cette dire faut de donner
les moyens d'agir et on les a pas
suffisamment et on sort d'une situation
absolument invraisemblable souvenez-vous
il ya quelques années on parle de la
suppression des départements c'était les
jeux tournent trop où on allait bâtir la
france avec l'état on allait bâtir la
france avec lille métropole dont elle va
dire la france avec des grandes régions
faire grand c'était la réponse on a eu
en fait de crise
la première crise c'était celle du gilet
jaune on a redécouvert l'importance de
la proximité de la réponse de proximité
et l'aspiration du peuple à avoir des
réponses avec la diversité territoriale
qu'on connaît en france
et puis le faire quand on a man démontré
que bassett et en situation de répondre
à tous les enjeux du quotidien
c'est là que département ont repris
toute leur place et est donc moi ce que
le message que je voudrais adresser
aujourd'hui c'est que les départements
sont devenus la collectivité essentiel
de la proximité
alors évidemment quand on parle de
technique c'est compliqué entre les
différents échelons on va avoir des
élections régionales en même temps que
départemental
ça va rajouter à la confusion moi ce que
j'observe c'est que les maires quand ils
ont un problème aujourd'hui avec le
départ d'un certain nombre de services
de l'état de nos territoires de nos
quartiers même si on a créé des grandes
agences et que c'était en disant on est
revenu mais ils ont pas les moyens
la grande force du département c'est
c'est sa capacité à agir au quotidien
moi je suis le président d'un
département de 698 commune 698 demain
matin on dit on va distribuer des
masques dans toutes les communes en 48
heures on a distribué des masques
pourquoi parce qu'on a conservé nos
services de proximité service d'incendié
de secours on a des centres de secours
qui assurent la sécurité de nos
compatriotes des biens et des personnes
on assume au quotidien la solidarité
pour que personne ne se sentent isolés
dans toute commune
on a investi dans le très haut débit qui
l'aurait fait mais voilà que l'état nous
dit écoutez il faut faire mieux faut
faire plus voilà les ordres qu'on nous
donne ne vous donne pas plus de moyens
débrouillez vous c'est ça qui va pas
aujourd'hui dans le pays via un pays
réel ayant un pib dia tic qui ne se rend
pas compte de l'importance aujourd'hui
du département dans la vie quotidienne
des gens moi j'aimerais que vraiment
j'aimerais que vraiment on vienne
assister à des assemblées de mer nous
disent voilà aider nous et on est là en
permanence c'est ça la leçon qu'il faut
tirer faire grand c'est pas de réponse
alors il faut que l'état simplement tiré
la leçon de tout ça il faut que d'abord
il assume ses missions mais que les
grandes missions régaliennes elles ne
peuvent avoir son prolongement dans la
vie quotidienne que si on s'appuie sur
les échelons territoriaux
on a redécouvert l'importance dé beir on
n' y aurait un peu trop les départements
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui le moment est
venu de redire à les interroger nos
compatriotes comme vous l'avez fait avec
les conseillers départementaux et vous
verrez alors soit on parle et on va en
parler tout à l'heure dans l'émission de
décentralisation et aider et des vrais
problèmes de fond que vous venez de
soulever mais avant de rejoindre mix
bussereau et jérôme fourquet à un mot
peut-être oui je voulais juste rebondir
sur ce que disait
le président sur sa référence à la crise
des gilets jaunes sais pas si vous vous
souvenez des images de ces
manifestations
beaucoup de gilet jaune plusieurs type
d'image oui mais moi non mais dans tout
souvent beaucoup de gilet jaune avait
écrit au marqueur noir le numéro de leur
département
au dos de leur gilet jaune un dock il y
avait quand même cette identification
départements qui étaient restées très
fortes dans cette population qu'on
appelle celle de la france périphérique
c'est un petit clin d'oeil à ce que
disait le président sauvadet c'est à
dire que pour beaucoup de ces français
l'échelon ou la maille départementale
parle encore très fortement
dominique bussereau un mot sur sur sur
l'étude finalement le poids politique de
l'assemblée des départements de france
des régions de la mf
il aurait été utile parce que à titre
personnel je n'ai jamais entendu autant
de manques gouvernement de parler de
territorialisation que depuis quelques
jours l'un territorialisation on voit
bien que c'est d'un la bonne réponse la
crise eu copie
le problème qu'on a eu au début avec les
échanges personnels de santé
c'est parce qu'on avait fait ses agences
des petits ministères celle une région
et qu'ils avaient le hoquet un parisien
de raison d'ailleurs pour lesquelles je
vous demande et les régions les
départements être plus dans la
gouvernance et d'un chemisier bleu santé
pour que les choses se passent
différemment je vais dire trois choses
par rapport à ces départs ont provoqué
par mes deux collègues et amis un
d'identification du département elle est
très forte que nous sommes avec avec
jean luc gleyze dans une région de tout
ce département avec plus de 500 km entre
le nord et le sud
correspond à un état européen moyen
comme l'autriche ou de l'admr vous voit
bien que
quel que ceux des communes son espace de
vie auquel on est tous viscéralement
attachés et le bon espace de solidarité
dans la région ils portent bien sûr
c'est très grands projets
d'infrastructure et développement et que
le vix et départements et puis la
modernité des départements c'est c'est
françois sur la dga mais qui dit qui en
a parlé c'est la fibre c'est nous qu'un
sale on affine le plus par hectare
sauf quelques villes ce sont les
départements qui vont faire en sorte que
dans chaque ferme dans chaque
exploitation ostréicole chez moi dans
chaque résidence secondaire chaque
petite entreprise artisanale à retenir
la fibre les salafis aujourd'hui c'est
la modernité est encore plus
indispensable avec le télétravail et
avec la taille de nous donner enfin une
réaction un peu plus politique sur ce
qu'a dit jérôme fourquet sur le bidon
moi j'ai voté contre les peuples vidéo
j'étais député de l'opposition
je veux des comptes parce que je disais
il ya un député et un verre et aux
autres régions présent département et
jean rien et comprend en réalité c'est
très efficace
d'abord en effet est-ce que ça permet la
parité 2 parce que collègues féminines
ont fait preuve de grandes qualités de
travail d' acharnement au travail de
leurs terres dans leur domaine et en
réalité c'est même pas une vidéo de
progrès on élit quelques personnes parce
que quand vous avez des cantons et
aujourd'hui on est à peu près la
dimension certaines circonscriptions
législatives il ya 20 ou 30 ans on fait
très attention à la représentation
géographique
je vois bien toutes les candidatures qui
paraissent dans la presse dans le
département comme dans les autres
départements de france à quelle personne
un minot il ya deux remplaçants qui sont
souvent des gens importants deiber est
donc cette troupe c'est trop grand
canton sont heureusement a beaucoup
pensé par le fait que quatre personnes
deux incarnent
moi j'ai toujours veillé dans mon
département a associé les remplaçants au
travail de l'assemblée faire en sorte
qu'ils ne soient pas là simplement pour
apporter des suffrages mais qu'il puisse
à tout moment être opérationnel dans le
travail de l'assemblée lentement
merci beaucoup dominique bussereau
seront fort qu'elle allait rester avec
nous parce qu'on va aborder la deuxième
partie de cette émission consacrée au
thème d'actualité on a commencé un peu
en par les crises sanitaires
décentralisation on se retrouve dans
quelques instants
et
[Musique]
voilà je vais fourquet bon je sais pas
si je vais bien résumé les thèmes qu'il
a peut-être d'autres d'actualité je
pense à la décentralisation bien sûr je
pense au rôle des collectivités locales
dans la crise sanitaire je pense aussi à
la demande bas forte de
territorialisation est-ce que vous avez
noté comme moi que jamais finalement
plus qu'en ce moment le gouvernement le
président de la république le premier
ministre
on emploie il emploie maintenant pas
tous bords mais beaucoup ce mot de
territorialisation oui tout à fait alors
on peut même faire remonter ça un peu
plus loin on parlait tout à l'heure de
la crise des gilet jaune
on a un pouvoir central qui a
redécouvert lice l'existence des
collectivités locales et des élus locaux
à l'occasion de cette crise rappelez
vous que la première étape est le
premier publics visités dans le lors du
grand débat lors de toux de france des
manuels mâcon c'est lé maire mais ruraux
dans le calvados je crois ou en
normandie en tout cas qui est qui avait
été qui avaient été visités qui avait
été consulté par le président de la
république donc là il sent bien ce
président de la république et le
gouvernement qu'il faut s'appuyer sur ce
qui fonctionne en france et notamment
sur ces collectivités territoriales pour
associer associer ces élus mais
également conférer davantage de
souplesse et d'agilité dans l'action
publique parce que là encore je parlais
de crash-tests tout à l'heure on a parlé
des drs il ya quand même un bilan à
tirer de tout cela et beaucoup l'ont
fait de leur côté il n'est pas forcément
très reluisant sur ces thèmes
d'actualité je vais revenir vers eux
jean-luc eux claeys françois sauvadet
pour leur demander un peu comment
comment il aborde ces thèmes d'actualité
par rapport à leur département par
rapport au territoire mais je me faut
que juste une dernière question
on a besoin de votre analyse à ce stade
est ce que vous pensez que il y aura un
avant et un après crise sanitaire du
point de vue du rôle central des
départements dans la politique au sens
large du pays est-ce que sans modifier
une constitution on peut imaginer que
toutes les leçons quel que soit le
pouvoir en place à paris auront été
tirée de l'épisode compliqué dramatique
que nous vivons on peut le souhaiter
elle espérait l'avenir nous dira si
7ce voeu est exaucé en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que tout ça est restée
gravée dans la mémoire de l'opinion
publique c'est à dire qu'encore une fois
le réflexe premier de la société
française c'était de se tourner vers
l'état et on s'est aperçu que l'état
central n'était pas en capacité de
d'apporter toutes les réponses en tout
cas dans les délais impartis et donc
tout ça laissera des traces d'auxi ce
que vous évoquiez n'advient pas
prochainement ce sera très très
dommageable et il y aura des demandes
dans la population pour aller vers vers
cela donc en part si on parle très
clairement je pense que des candidats
qui portrait dans le cadre la prochaine
élection présidentielle
un message clair en termes de
décentralisation bénéficierait d'une
écoute plus attentive de toute une
partie de la population
jean-luc laisse vous avez l'impression
que avec cette crise sanitaire
grâce à cette crise sanitaire mais avec
cette crise sanitaire
la demande de territorialisation et plus
forte auprès de vos administrés
on ne vous entend pas mais je pense
qu'on va rétablir la leçon tout de suite
jean-luc l'aise je vais reformuler ma
question est ce que vous avez
l'impression suite aux propos de jérôme
fourquet qu'il ya une demande qui va
croissante de territorialisation parce
que les citoyens parce que les
administrés ont bien vu que les
collectivités territoriales et notamment
les départements répondait au mieux à
leurs attentes dans cette période
compliquée alors je n'aime pas trop le
terme de territorialisation sur le vote
est clos
j'ai envie de parler proximité parce que
finalement ce que les temps les gens
attendent c'est vraiment cette proximité
la france ô sera d'évoquer tout à
l'heure ce côté un petit peu grand de
l'état je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce
qui est attendu c'est plutôt logique
small is beautiful c'est à dire que plus
je les chansons petit plus est en fait
un ancien lui courant proximité ils ont
une importance au local rapport aux
centrales est bien plus aujourd'hui nous
sommes en capacité de réponse aux
besoins de deux des gens besoins du
peuple autour de nous et nous avons à
être à cette écoute là je pense que la
crise a effectivement démontré plus que
jamais la nécessité d'être au plus prêt
que la réponse est finalement passe par
le contact quasiment direct que l'on
peut avoir
les élus locaux vers la population et
donc l'organisation nationale qui doit
définir un cadre régalien certes qui
doit définir aussi un cadre légal qu'il
faut appliquer qui doit garantir et
contrôle d'un manteau de notre
république que sont la liberté l'égalité
la fraternité et tout cela doit atterrir
sous la forme de la décentralisation de
la proximité
je suis très j'ai un souvenir du grand
débat à bordeaux avec le président macro
est cependant là qui semblait opposer
décentralisation égalité républicaine en
dix ans lorsqu on permet au département
d'opérer en termes de politiques
publiques
chacun à leur manière ça n'est pas une
forme de garantie de l'égalité
républicaine
moi je pense d'eux est très dangereux
d'avoir ce type de propos là je pense
qu'il revient au pouvoir législatif donc
au législateur de faire en sorte de
garantir le cadre pour 7 pour cette
égalité républicaine
il revient au gouvernement évidemment
d'entre eux sont assurés mais nous
sommes en capacité nous dans les
départements en particulier
de pratiquer des politiques publiques
qui peuvent être un peu différenciée qui
peuvent être un peu expérimentale
innovantes et nous avons démontré dans
le département combien nous le saurons
cours de la dernière mandature
on a proposé notamment l'expérimentation
comme celle du revenu de base qui
malheureusement n'ont pas été retenus et
pour autant il me semble qu'il faut
laisser la liberté aux départements de
tenter l'expérimentation tout en
respectant les grandes règles de la
république et les grands principes
républicains et que c'est de cette
manière que nous serons beaucoup plus à
l'écouté beaucoup plus en proximité par
rapport à nos populations
françois sauvadet en côte d'or on
préfère le mot de territorialisation de
proximité écoute et on va pas se battre
sur les mots à moi je suis d'accord il
jean luc jean luc gleyze sur ce constat
d'abord l'état il faut qu'il fasse une
réponse globale
on est face à une pandémie on a pris
toutes les garanties on nous dit faut
vacciner
bon mais là c'est là que le problème
commence c'est à dire qu'on confond dans
les services de l'état l'information des
élus locaux avec la concertation que les
élus locaux là pour faire bien pour nous
dire on va massifier la vaccination
on nous annonce des grands vaccinodromes
va très bien alors évidemment on en a ou
verra au zénith ce matin même au zénith
de dijon
et pendant ce temps là on ferme dans les
quartiers sensibles le centre de
vaccination le ferment en périphérie on
en a fermé
est ce que c'est la bonne réponse non
parce que vous imaginez que les gens qui
ont déjà des doutes sur la vaccination
l'astra zeneca et cetera ils vont encore
aller se précipiter pour faire des
longues files d'attentes avec des
professionnels de santé qui travaillent
à proximité
donc moi je suis à faire dans partisans
d'une réponse globale celle route de
l'état mais d'une adaptation et d' une
territorialisation des politiques
moi aujourd'hui je suis dans un
département je voulais dit la moitié de
la population est concentrée sur une
seule ville tout le restant est
concentré sur 650 communes va concentrer
vous voyez ce que je veux dire comment
on fait donc moi ce que je souhaite
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on travaille en
concertation
les ars se sont comportés de manière
arrogante en matière de santé et en
matière de réponse
on a commandé des millions de masques y
compris des régions s'en sont mêlés puis
d'un seul coup tout le monde se
regardait en disant comment va les
distribuer il faut qu'on redécouvre en
france la grande chance d'avoir des
départements pourquoi parce que nous
avons des services territoriaux
moi j'ai deux mille huit cents agents
sur un département comme le mien plus
des trois quarts sont sur le terrain
donc si on a besoin d'être à proximité
pour une réponse individuelle
aujourd'hui les gens aspirent une
réponse pour rompre et françois souvenez
selon jour là christian sur la question
des ars ou vous en avait trop dit ou pas
assez vite mais l'arrogance vous dites
l'arrogance des arn des ingrédients sont
des régionales de santé
mais c'est quoi c'est la lourdeur
administrative d'un certain succès
nous sommes nous sommes en co
responsabilité par exemple nous
établissements pour personnes âgées
dépendantes comme présidente ce
département de la côte d'or
j'ai passé quatre mois on se refuse à me
donner le nombre de personnes qui est
atteinte de la comédie qui décédé dans
les ehpad des vous vous rendez compte
alors que nous sommes encore
responsabilité donc c'est absolument
invraisemblable cette absence de
confiance on remontait à paris des
informations pour les redescendre
alors qu'on aurait pu immédiatement
intervenir dès qu'on avait à 4 go vite
dans un ehpad un cas de collines pour
dire ben voilà on ferme le périmètre de
l'ehpad
on interdit les visites des personnes
âgées pour éviter la propagation du
virus
on n'avait même pas des informations
c'est vous dire dans quel état d'esprit
nous sommes aujourd'hui moi je découvre
je découvre l'ouverture de la fermeture
d'un vaccinaux de là provient de changer
on dit vite donc les pompiers on
pourrait pas les mobiliser m'enfin on
est dans un monde
invraisemblable je vous le dis il faut
que ce gouvernement arrête de faire de
la com et se disent que ce qui intéresse
les gens c'est qu'on soit sérieux
on attendait je termine là dessus on a
brassé de vaccins moi j'ai plaidé depuis
le début non seulement une adaptation
mais quand on a dit on vaccine les plus
de 75 ans mais bon on s'organise avec
tous les élus locaux pour aller chercher
chaque personne qui est en capacité qui
voulait faire vacciner pour être
vaccinés on avait à peine terminé compte
et on était à 30% des vaccinations pour
les 75 ans et on me disait des gens
accès dacia va vacciner les 65 ans et 50
ans mais c'est invraisemblable c'est
donc je vais aussi entre les astres à
cerizay et la réalité que ce creux je
voudrais à l'idea compréhension oui oui
je voudrais je voudrais aussi interrogé
sur le même sujet
bussereau mais juste on a un manque de
vaccins mais ça dépend duquel parce que
vous savez aussi qu'avec les pataquès de
communication autour d'un vaccin anglais
qui s'appelle astrazeneca il ya des
doses qui sont en place et personne me
faire vacciner
y compris cinq ambassadeurs avec
astrazeneca eric revel permettez moi de
vous le dire cette grand bazar moi je
suis en contact chaque jour avec des
compatriotes
j'avais des gens qui à 55 ans pourrait
se faire vacciner pendant qu'une
personne à 81,2 n'était pas encore
vaccinée savais pas comment j'allais
faire
enfin il ya un moment donné il faut
revenir sur des objectifs et se fixer
des objectifs et nous nous ne sommes pas
contre le gouvernement nous sommes pas
contre l'état
nous voulons être des acteurs à part
entière pour réussir dans des enjeux qui
sont des enjeux fondamentaux et on ne
gagnera pas des batailles comme celle là
sans la proximité sans écouter la
personne qui dit je ne peux pas me
déplacer depuis ma maison à marigny le
k-way comment je fais pour me faire
vacciner
c'est ça la question de fond dominique
bussereau bon là je m'adresse pas au
président de l'assemblée des
départements de france mais au président
du conseil départemental de charente
maritime
voilà un département qu'un taux
d'incidence à seebach et tant mieux pour
les charentais maritimes comment est ce
que vous avez vécu au quotidien cette
crise sanitaire vous êtes aussi dur avec
la rs et les services administratifs de
l'état que l'était françois sauvadet
je pense que l'étincelle agit en cas de
crise en matière fécale il j'ai connu
aussi tiens nous pose un vendéen tous
morts en 1990
13 morts l'état est formidable pour
amener des camions au pied les
hélicoptères les colonnes de la sécurité
civile
voilà organisé la première riposte quand
il s'agit de construire de donner des
réfrigérateurs aux gens prenant maisons
détruit un peu d'argent de quoi sourire
il sait absolument pas faire parce qu'au
fil des gouvernements à découvrir
également qu'elle n'a pas retenu
on a complètement cassé les services de
l'état déchets départementale regroupés
dans les grandes directions régionales
donc maintenant en réalité des préfets
je parle est vrai que le département
c'est peut-être un peu moins valable
pour les préfets de région ont des
équipes très restreinte autour d'eux et
en effet comme l'elysée françois
sauvadet son département qui s'en sort
le terrain et et sont les départements
qui agissent qui agissent réellement en
proximité en période de crise les ars
ont pris le pouvoir
en réalité il eût fallu confier cette
mission au préfet qu'ils ont l'habitude
de travailler
les élus et gendarmes avec les pompiers
et les policiers
et puis police municipale et les 1eres
communiquer même pas et qu'elle
préférait jeu pour prendre l'exemple de
françois sauvadet dans une communion
départementaux des charentes à côté leur
joie sur bare 14 ans dans un ehpad 14
ans dans un état d'une dizaine de jours
le maire n'était pas au courant
le département autorité conjointe de
régulation départ ou plus le préfet
encore - et même pour tout dire j'ai un
peu du gérant lui-même son cabinet et la
direction générale de la santé n'étaient
pas au courant
un système qui se mord la queue et il
faut en effet que
les ars ils sont pas nouveau les
inventions je préfère des rsa ministère
centralisées à paris
il faut que les ars se concentre sur le
niveau départemental qui renforce niveau
départemental elles ont commencé à le
faire je dois dire la vérité il
recommence à le faire après les leçons
de la première crise et puis il faut
qu'on y soit il faut que le président de
région
par exemple le président du conseil
d'administration de la rs il faut voir
l'état gare de son rôle de régulateur
sur le terrain une vision des choses au
sens on perd un temps fou dans ces
vaccins dont les gens ne veulent pas
sans compter en effet les erreurs comme
sur la stratégie qu'a qui fait que
l'offre vous a été compliqué à quelqu'un
vous avez été vaccinées à la stratégie
cas on prend pour un bouc
parce que lui il est beaucoup plus
intelligent et beaucoup plus de relation
ils étaient vaccinés au freezer à tout
ça est quand même le profondément
ridicule et moi je pense que il faut
refaire les choses en profiter il faut
d'ailleurs voir la décentralisation
donner plus de pouvoir au préfet pour
que les préfets de département puissent
gérer des choses directement sans passer
par une direction régionale nous on
nouvelle équipe est une passe au
contrôle de jon leyne savons
l'agriculture à limoges l'environnement
à poitiers d'autres directions à
bordeaux que notre capitale régionale
est ce qui fait que c'est direction d'un
tract au ministère est prêt qui préfet
de département et ça ne fonctionne pas
donc il faut que l'état lui-même se
remette au niveau départemental sangally
effectifs naturellement et remettre des
effectifs au niveau départemental il
faut que nous ayons un partage des rôles
dans lequel nous sommes les uns les
autres plus efficaces pour nos
concitoyens
je reviens pardonnez moi c'est à la fois
l'esprit en escalier puis un peu une
marotte
quelle leçon à tirer de tout ça d'un
point de vue de l'organisation
administrative et politique jacobins
versus girondins est ce que vous pensez
quand on entend françois sauvadet ou
jean nucléaire ou le président bussereau
de cibler un peu montré du doigt ce
rouages administratifs qui est la rs6 on
pouvait tirer une leçon ce serait
d'organiser un peu tout ça pour que ça
fonctionne mieux et notamment plus avec
les territoires et notamment les
départements
oui alors
il ya cette crise du coc vide et il ya
également ce qui se passe ce qui s'est
passé en parallèle et qui continue de se
passer maintenant on en a pas parlé
jusqu'à présent et c'est mon beaucoup
moins les compétences du département
mais ça va avoir un effet sur ce que je
vais dire après sur en matière de
délinquance et d'insécurité
c'est à dire que là où on attend l'état
prioritairement c'est sur le régalien et
une majorité de nos concitoyens
considèrent que la mission n'est pas
remplie et que la justice n'est pas
assez sévère que les forces de l'ordre
ne disposent pas suffisamment de moyens
etc l inverse sur la proximité le social
etc
on a des collectivités locales qui
savent bien faire qu'ils ont montrée
très concrètement pendant une crise
comme le co vide qu'elle était un quand
elle était à la manoeuvre
elle pouvait délivrer du résultat est là
on a un état qui s'est caractérisée par
sa capacité à mettre des bâtons dans les
roues
je reviens avec mon histoire de masques
qui était saisie et que c'est donc c'est
à dire s'il fallait simplifier on ans il
faut que l'état soit plus fort sur ses
fonctions et ses missions régaliennes et
que sur tout le reste
non pas qu'il se désengage mais ce qu'on
a entendu c'est une question d'attitude
c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'ils fassent
confiance et qu'il lâche la bride si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi aux collectivités
si laval sujet des ateliers des
départements met en mode raid pas vous
poser la question il faut qu'elle a vous
nous faites ou nounous rédiger un peu
une feuille de route là pour une
élection qui aura lieu le 2 je réponds
oui on va vous parler du régalien vous
dites y'a pas assez de forces de polices
oui mais justement le président devant
un public et peut-être candidat sécu
section vient de saupoudrer un peu
partout des effectifs de nouveau de
forces de l'ordre on est dedans on est
dans ce schéma politique là alors oui il
ya sept ans contre fois je vous dis
c'est pas assez fort là il faudra l'être
et pas assez
comment dire en proximité sur les autres
thématiques et donc encore une fois je
pense que de la crise due qu'au guide et
de ce qui se passe depuis si les
français ont tiré une conclusion en
termes d'organisation des pouvoirs
c'est plus de proximité et plus de
décentralisation de pouvoir et
d'autonomie aux collectivités locales
qui savent faire et que l'état s'occupe
mais s'occupe bien d'eux sort pour ce
pourquoi il a été pensé et créé
historiquement alors je le disais tout à
l'heure en commençant cette émission
parmi les thèmes d'actualité évidemment
il y en a un qui va peut-être encore
plus fâché les présidents de
départements qui est le thème de la
décentralisation qui est concomitant
évidemment avec les sujets qu'on a
abordé notamment la question et la
gestion jacobine de la crise sanitaire
jean-luc l'aise quel regard vous portez
aujourd'hui sur l'état de la
décentralisation en vous colle des
choses à faire mais on vous donne pas
les moyens c'est un peu caricatural mais
je suis dans le vrai oui vous êtes dans
le vrai complètement c'est à dire que
nous sentons bien le besoin et en
viennent de dire pendant toute la
première partie de cette émission le
besoin de proximité le besoin d'action
directe qui oppose de la technostructure
aux élus locaux la vision de la vision
administrative
al'approche terrain la complexité à la
simplicité est donc le vrai sujet
aujourd'hui une loi qui s'appelle 4d et
qui comprend deux termes qui devraient
être complémentaires mais je suis pas
certain que la vision de l'état et du
gouvernement c'est tout à fait
équilibrée sur le sujet déconcentration
et décentralisation
le vrai sujet c'est la décentralisation
est ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui c'est
que le projet qui portaient les lois
capoter le projet petit bras qui n'est
pas du tout à la hauteur du souffle
décentralisateur qui est absolument
nécessaire désormais qu'il en fait
répond la première décentralisation
il avait 80 portés par de faire une
seconde décentralisation porté par
raffarin par la suite et qui aujourd'hui
nécessiterait d'être ré oxygéner
revitaliser et plus encore à l'autre de
la crise sanitaire
or aujourd'hui ce sens en bien c'est
cette espèce est épais de frioul de
frilosité que peut avoir le gouvernement
qui essaie de donner l'impression qu'il
est en train de s'occuper de ce qui va
se passer sur le terrain mais en réalité
sauf sur les transferts de compétences
qui ne sont pas financés avec les moyens
nécessaires et ça ça n'est pas
acceptable
sommes sur une réorganisation qui
favorise plutôt la présence de l'état
vont avec son contrôle par rapport aux
collectivités locales
je rappelle l'article 72 de la
constitution qui prévoit la libre
administration des collectivités locales
s'est dit est ce champ là qu'il faut
creuser travailler beaucoup plus que ce
qui est aujourd'hui prévue au travers
d'une sorte de rubik's cube dans lequel
les éléments qui ont du mal à sa droite
et au travers de la loi bachelot des
monts françois sauvadet bon je vais vous
titiller un peu vous vouliez plus de
rôle vous en avez plus grâce à la
décentralisation fait pas vous plaire ah
oui ben ça j'aimerais bien non
j'aimerais bien
eric revel non en fait voilà la
décentralisation c'est quoi c'est
qu'elle est le beau deschamps pourra
pour agir
c'est ça la décentralisation alors il ya
le rôle régalien on vient d'en parler
c'est pas notre sujet encore que les
aspects périphériques de la sécurité
parce que quand il ya de la sécurité et
des comportements déviants chez des
jeunes qui sont mineurs non accompagnés
ou des jeunes isolés on nous les
confient et là quelques fois je tends je
sens qu'en matière pédopsychiatrique en
matière de problématiques de violence de
jeunes on est un peu tout seul les
serres tout seul et on ne pointe du
doigt en disant qu'est ce que vous
faites
donc il faut que l'état assume
clairement ses missions moi ce que je
revendique aujourd'hui c'est la capacité
à faire et ce que je regrette c'est
qu'entre les grandes déclarations qui
sont faites
oui on a confiance dans les
connectivités wi lan via de la proximité
qu'est ce qu'on constate en fait les
moyens financiers on est étranglé la
crise des vous bien les choses elle est
devant nous et là on va être au côté de
l'état aux premières lignes le rsa les
familles en difficulté les violences
faites aux femmes violentées bretons
enfants c'est notre compétence le monde
du handicap
c'est notre compétence les dépenses
augmentent en flèche évidemment il ya
une crise et on fera face mais en même
temps nous plafond de dépenses en tout
cas on envisage de nour plafonnier de
dépendre comment s'en sort dans tout ça
on est dans un monde de fous
et troisièmement on nous a interdit
toute possibilité d'avoir recours à un
impôt c'est à dire que maintenant c'est
l'état qui nous donne une dotation
donc on est complètement ficelles et
quand on parle décentralisation l'état
nous dit ah bah oui bon vas déconcentrés
des services de l'état mais c'est pas ça
la décentralisation la décentralisation
c'est de redonner aux pouvoirs locaux
les moyens d'agir et d'agir vraiment moi
je ne demande pas tout faire mais comme
moi dans les mises
on compte confie on soit pas en train de
décider depuis paris avec des
injonctions permanente dans tous les
domaines y compris dans la protection de
l'enfance et ça j'ai trouvé que les
procès qui nous sont faits ils sont
insupportables
vous savez si les daces de ya trente ans
elle est en capacité de mieux s'occuper
des enfants d'aujourd'hui faudrait nous
le dire est qu'on le conte les recréer
mais en réalité il faut vraiment qu'on
ait un souffle décentralisateur que
l'état arrête de nous donner des
injonctions faut augmenter les salaires
de pompiers très bien comment on fait
quand avec des salaires plafonnés avec
des revenus plafonnés faut augmenter les
aides à domicile bien sûr qu'il faut les
revaloriser et c'est nous qui allons
payer comme on fait donc c'est ça qu'il
faut clarifier
moi je ne demande pas tout faire mais
comme donne les moyens de faire et qu'on
en discute ensemble
si c'est pour aller dans des réunions
comme on l'a fait trop souvent ces
derniers temps pour qu'on nous informe
de la décision en disant prenez là parce
que si vous la prenez pas ce sera pire
est ce que c'est ça une réponse
responsable dans un pays où chacun doit
être responsable et en situation de
responsabilité
moi je suis pas contre le gouvernement
je dis simplement au gouvernement
travaillons ensemble sur les objectifs
dites ce que vous faites de fait peu et
puis laissez nous faire sur ce qui nous
est confié et donnez nous les moyens de
le faire en tout cas laisser nous agir
voilà la question de la décentralisation
et là on est dans un vent de
recentralisation permanent la haute
technocratie en matière de santé en
matière de pouvoir à j'étais ministre de
la fonction publique dont je le vois
bien il faut une profonde réforme de
l'état et que chacun revienne à sa place
le pouvoir régalien est régalien le
pouvoir des collectivités locales doit
être reprécisée et et voilà c'est aussi
simple que ça nous maintenons bien de
chercher surtout beaucoup la région qui
est en capacité de faire pour
l'agriculture médian pas signer une
convention
vous n'avez plus la compétence mais des
nounours et pas faire seul bacon
clarifier tout ça enfin c'est ça qu'on
attend donc les lois 4d on peut rajouter
cinq des six des dix des bains c'est une
loi qui est décédée pour la
décentralisation c'est pas mal la
formule est pas mal françois sauvadet
dominique bussereau guillois à cadets et
puis financement du rsa si j'ai bonne
mémoire lors d'une adresse du président
de la république à la nation il avait
annoncé
il ya une augmentation du rsa dont le
financement a été refilée passez moi
l'expression département est ce que le
président de l'assemblée des
départements de france avait été
consulté le plus il en a fait venir un
jour pour me dire je vais faire le
revenu qui l'a remplacé toutes les
locaux dans la travail anses depuis
fortis sont athées que cette affaire n'a
pas avancé et c'est dommage ça peut être
une réponse y compris à la revendication
de vos collègues de gauche leur donne
une base voilà mais voilà les choses
n'ont pas rasées donc qu'est ce qui se
passe maintenant un nouvel accent trois
allocations lapin a parlé tout à l'heure
pour les personnes âgées
nous versons une allocation
complémentaire pour le mica et vincent
perez a géré ça depuis martin hirsch un
secrétaire d'état qui crée récent
remplacement des ready il devrait être
financée à 100% par l'état au début
d'ailleurs quand jean pierre raffarin
transférer les répit aux collectivités
en l'occurrence et départements ils
étaient financés à 100% au fil des
années si j'étais vous dimanche et 18
budget je connais bien merci
puis les années en bessin lice pour son
entité aujourd'hui elle aperçoit leur
métier et c'est pas normal s'il voulait
nous sommes sains
nous alimentons des personnes
apportaient de la solidarité nationale
gérant la solidarité nationale sur le
terrain girondin sections les plus
importants et n'ont pas les moyens de le
faire ce qui fait que certains
départements certainement essoufflé -
d'insertion parce qu'il fallait quand
même verser le rsa et donc ça se faisait
au détriment des politiques de
l'insertion
donc il faut véritablement revenir
dessus ou alors gouvernement
recentralise du rsa nous avons sept
départements sur les 103 qui sont
volontaires travaillent et le
gouvernement sur ces lits peut-être
regardons comment se déroule ce travail
mais si on reste
personnellement j'y sois il faut que
nous ayons les met à le faire le rsa a
grossi en france ou miss nationale est à
peu près de 10% pm et ça va augmenter
je vois bien un département où le
premier collègues voient tous les
français dès que les petits commerces
qui vont pas réouvrir bien calé café qui
nous paraît ouvrir et les professionnels
du tourisme qui nous mourir qu'il y a ça
tombe de jean et qui sont peut-être
parfois plus près de la retraite que de
la poursuite de leurs activités le mac
ou jerez avant l'augmentation du rsa va
être considérable il faut que l'état
donne les moyens de verser c'est
vraiment ce que disent les deux
collègues nous demandons pas le grand
soir nommant chacun fasse bien se méfier
nous demandons que le grand particulier
une compétence de solidarité sociale
faveur des enfants des jeunes des
collégiens des 400 âgées des handicapés
nous puissions les assumer à 100 % car
il ya encore de la misère sociale dans
notre pays et sont les départements avec
les communes qui sont à la tâche pour
essayer d'écouter nos concitoyens
j'aimerais vous poser une dernière
question pour terminer ces émissions
cette émission centrée sur les ateliers
des départements avec vous jean luc
lahaye ce qu'on le dit assez souvent on
l'entend assez souvent on est dans une
crise sanitaire qui va devenir une crise
économique est forcément une crise
sociale alors c'est vrai qu'on a des
amortisseurs sociaux en france solide
que beaucoup de pays peuvent nous envier
même s'il faut les financer il est payé
un jour aussi bien pour les salariés que
pour les entreprises
est ce que vous craignez dans votre
département de la gironde jean luc
lahaye ce que cette crise sociale soit
extrêmement puissante et que finalement
le département que vous présidez ne
puisse pas y faire face alors je ne fais
pas que le crains que je constate c'est
à dire que fans 2000 var nous avions
trois mille demandeurs de rsa donc
allocataires du rsa supplémentaires par
rapport à ce que nous avions connu en
2010 d'heure c'est à dire à peu près de
12 millions d'euros
de plus et surtout ce qui m'a beaucoup
inquiété c'est qu'il ya comme il ya un
pourcentage relativement important de
personnes qui habituellement ne venait
pas solliciter le rsa je pense notamment
aux travailleurs indépendants qui
on a réussi à passer cette étape de
crise ce qui dure et qui donc se sont
retrouvés du jour au lendemain sans
protection sociale avec la nécessité de
solliciter la location du rsa donc je
suis convaincu aujourd'hui que la crise
économique qui risque peut-être de
s'apaiser un peu avec le le sentiment de
reprise avec le déconfinement l'a
néanmoins entraîner un certain nombre de
dépôts de bilan et de liquidations
d'entreprises faut savoir quand même que
les prêts garantis par l'état devront
être un jour remboursés et que si le
chiffre d'affaires n'est pas à la
hauteur pour faire face à la fois aux
charges quotidiennes et ensuite à la
nécessité de remboursement un certain
nombre d'entreprises dont ceux trouvés
en difficulté même si nombreux ministres
des finances à décaler d'un an ou deux
le remboursement du prêt garanti par
l'état oui mais il n'empêche que il va
falloir que tu fasses atteint 40 piges
sont absolument pas riders pour tout le
monde du jet de l'ordinaire ça risque de
durer dans le temps
et puis regardez ce qui se passe quand
même au niveau de la jeunesse vous avez
un certain nombre de jeunes aujourd'hui
et quand je prends des jeunes c'est des
18 25 ans en particulier si elles font
parfois en très grande difficulté qui
ont des ruptures dans leur parcours de
cursus universitaire parce qu'ils
n'arrivent plus à payer leurs études
parce qu'ils n'ont plus accès au bout
dit john qui habituellement est leur
permettait de détail hors alimentation
et leur et leur logement et qui vont se
retrouver peut-être dans les difficultés
supplémentaires à terre avec la
nécessité de solliciter d'allocations
type rsa
je suis convaincu que la casse sociale
est à venir et qu'elle sera très
difficile et très dure à supporter pour
les départements il faut là encore elle
a 10 ans aurait dit tout à l'heure il
faut absolument que l'état soit à la
hauteur des financements qui nous sont
nécessaires
nos mini bus seront les montées
aujourd'hui l'état ne finance pas
suffisamment les allocations
individuelles de solidarité que nous
versons au titre de la solidarité
nationale
il faut que l'état soit au rendez-vous
aujourd'hui une crise sociale crise
avance et des difficultés que rencontre
notre pays un mot peut-être vers une
forte avant de donner la parole à
françois sauvadet et puis à 2010 trous
pour conclure dans d'autres enquêtes
d'opinion que que mène
l'ifop vous constatez cette montée
importante inquiétante de la crise
sociale alors oui non parce que on a
quand même c'est filets de protection
que vous indiquiez tout à l'heure qui
font que contrairement à d'autres pays
notamment ceux d'europe du sud pour
l'instant même s'il ya des publics comme
le disait le président anglaise qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude de voir dans le rouge
des indépendants des artisans autres
même si ces publics là peuvent être
fragilisés globalement l'édifice social
tiens tiens plutôt là où les choses vont
se compliquer et c'est ce que tout le
monde redoute c'est quand
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi on va
progressivement retiré la perfusion et
que on va retourner dans dans le grand
bain donc pour l'instant on ad on a des
signes sur certains publics qui ce qui
se fragilise
mais on n'a pas un effondrement qui se
dessine là où comme souvent les choses
se compliquent c'est que cette crise a
frappé beaucoup plus durement et ça on
le voit très clairement les publics les
plus précaires
aujourd'hui un français sur deux nous
dit que il a été touché personnellement
par cette crise économique et sociale je
parle pas du fait d'avoir été contaminé
ou pas c'est 20% dans les plus hauts des
cils c'est 75% dans les déciles les plus
modestes mais il n'y a pas d'argent
magique le quoi qu'il en coûte
phrase célèbre si l'on est un culte du
président de la république va toucher un
peu à sa fin il va il va durer encore un
an oui il va durer mais au moins
jusqu'aux estime être absolument c'est
que les aides dont vous parliez je pense
au fonds solidarité pour les entreprises
je pense au chômage partiel pour les
salariés en tout cas c'est annoncée
comme sa part le ministre des finances
tous savent à s'amortir tout doucement
progrès cement progressivement s'amortir
alors ya une campagne électorale non pas
départementales régionales mais
présidentielle qui s'annonce donc on
peut penser sans être grand clerc que la
perfusion va être un petit peu maintenue
même beaucoup maintenu pendant cette
période il n'en demeure pas moins que
certains secteurs on a on évoquait aussi
par exemple le tourisme dans certaines
dans certaines régions je pense
notamment régions de montagne régions
littorales
on a des professions des professions
entière qui vont être très très sinistré
donc on personne ne sait dire à l'heure
où on se parle
dans quel état on va retrouver le pays
quand on va sortir de cette espèce de
parenthèse
idem pour le secteur de la restauration
les estimations dont on dispose c'est
que d'après les professionnels il y
aurait un tiers des restaurants par
exemple qui ne retrouverait pas après
après l'appareil la période du coc vite
donc ça fait des dizaines et des
dizaines de milliers d'emplois et qui
vont qui vont disparaître comme ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure notamment pour
des publics qu'on n'avait pas l'habitude
de classer comme étant des publics qui
était précaire ou fragiles françois
sauvadet comment s'incarne la crise
sociale en côte d'or devant quelle
situation aujourd'hui
êtes vous confronté à quelles situations
parfois écoutez nous on est dans la même
situation que ce qui a décrit dominique
bussereau et jean luc gleyze
on a une montée de la précarité d'abord
chez les jeunes
moi je n'avais jamais vu ça des jeunes
qui n'ont plus de petits boulots des
jeux des étudiants des jeunes qui se
retrouvent avec des familles qui peuvent
pas les accompagner dans mon département
on a multiplié par 10 en quelques mois
l'aide alimentaire c'est-à-dire des
secours d'urgence l'aide alimentaire
multiplie par 10 en quelques mois donc
et puis des allocations d'urgence qu'on
donne aux familles pour faire face savez
dans un département comme le mien qui
est un des plus pauvres
530 mille habitants j'ai dix huit mille
familles monoparentales dont 80 % sont
des femmes
vous imaginez qu'ils n'avaient plus leur
boulot de parfois de nettoyage parfois
des boulots qui leur permettait de
survivre et on est confronté à une
montée de ces précarité je crains fort
que moi de septembre
effectivement comme l'a dit dominique
bussereau et jean-luc dans certaines
activités liées au tourisme la
restauration
on devra commencer à rembourser le pgr
on va rentrer dans une période hivernale
ensuite sans avoir les ressources de
trésorerie nécessaires pour y faire face
moi je crains que le pic de crise
sociale que nous allons connaître sera
pour après l'automne c'est-à-dire dans
la période hivernale moi je me prépare
franchement quand je vois à les écouter
dans un petit département comme le mien
grand par la réputation mais de 530
mille habitants j'ai fait un plan de
soutien de 30 2 millions d'euros plan de
soutien de 30 2 millions d'euros je ne
sais pas si vous imaginez sur un budget
de 500 à l'esa 130 millions donc cette
énorme et on devrait
faire face donc je dis au gouvernement
commençons à préparer tout cela moi je
suis papa pas favorable mais j'ai
peut-être une divergence avec jean-luc
là dessus pas favorables allocation
universelle pour tout le monde allait
voilà revenu minimum universel etc
moi je suis favorable à une
individualisation de l'aide
c'est à dire que chaque parcours est
différent on peut innover aussi en
matière sociale on l'a fait nous mêmes
on peut cumuler des petits travaux des
emplois du rsa etc
donc on peut innover et puis dans chaque
département il ya aussi en même temps
des métiers en tension
et c'est là où il faut qu'on organise
mieux les choses pour qu'on puise dans
les mé en tension par exemple pour les
vendanges moi je suis désolé on trouve
plus personne pour faire les vendanges
un problème quand même c'est pareil dans
le bordelais j'imagine donc il faut
vraiment et dans d'autres métiers des
métiers de la terre le métier de 2,2 de
la valorisation légumières et c'est tout
une somme de métier pour les dans les
métiers de la forêt par exemple ou dans
les métiers de l'aide sociale donc il
faut absolument qu'on ouvre des
perspectives aux peuples et par la
formation par l'accompagnement vers des
métiers en tension et que dans le même
temps soit solidaire on va avoir un vrai
choc
à la sortie du pedn gouvernement fait le
job jusqu'à présent mais la sortie je
sais pas comment on va faire avec un
plafonnement de nos dépenses qui se
profile et plus de ressources du tout
plus de marges de manoeuvre financières
plus aucune essais d'état qui nous donne
la dotation et qui va nous appeler à la
rescousse en lui disant écoutez mesdames
messieurs on va pas faire un plan de
sévérité mais où d'austérité mais valoir
que vous participiez à l'effort
collectif comment on fait on va me
laisser les gens mourir de son bord de
la rue je ne je vous assure je suis allé
sur le terrain comme mes collègues
présentent département et jean luc le
sait comme dominique il faut vraiment
qu'on fasse attention au soutien qu'on
devra apporter aux familles les plus
précaires
dominique bussereau sur ce que vous
venez d'entendre et puis aussi comment
la charente-maritime fait face à la
crise sociale
j'ai entendu le mode et du liant sûr que
j'ai aussi
dans ma vie personnelle les activités
d'enseignement je suis effaré par la
destra situe en effet pas de petits
boulots d'appoint pas de possibilité de
se nourrir convenablement donc en effet
développement de cette ressource a même
vu à la rochelle
cette fois sympathique d'ailleurs à une
compagnie de crs veut dire faire la
cuisine pour les étudiants à plusieurs
reprises c'était une relation qu'elle et
les autres n'étaient pas forcément
habituelle lorsqu'il y avait des
périodes de manifestations et on a dû
faire un plan étudiants pour les
étudiants de l'université de la rochelle
qui sont dix mille mais aussi ceux qu'on
oublie c'est des aiguilles en pts terre
les grands lycées un axe dts qui sont
des étudiants qui sont dans des lycées
complètement saoul et eric faye a pas de
resto lui il n'y a pas forcément de
restos du coeur et c'est donc trouver
les ordinateurs le cd preneur logement
les aider psychologiquement c'est à
c'est quand même terrible détresse pour
une jeunesse en 2021
un moment où par la voiture électrique
demandez ce qu'est dans la station
spatiale internationale que des
étudiants français
elle n'est pas les moyens de se nourrir
ou ne rien faire un stage ou des moyens
de trouver un client thibodeau ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup masse et le touriste
page remparts été vos premières
économies c'est le tourisme avant la
viticulture en à pêche l'ostréiculture
les industries le verrou bière ou
aéronautique et très franchement le
tourisme lui de mauvaises vacances de
pâques du fait du changement des dates
du changement le dernier moment que le
gouvernement a souhaité mettre en oeuvre
et autant les prévisions pour le
printemps
sont pas trop mauvais le tourisme
l'hôtellerie de plein air autant
l'hôtellerie traditionnelle dans la
restauration dans la location
les prévisions pour la chanson paroles
et regardons les grands groupes français
a le club med à 20 ou 30% ces clubs
ouverts à travers le monde
pierre et vacances qui gère les fans de
center parcs l'équitation est ordinaire
et caetera et en très très grande
difficulté
donc paris la ratp les difficultés des
ratés paix apparaît certes et parisiens
ou à travailler parce qu'ils sont et à
travers il ya plus toute la clientèle
touristique de nous du monde entier qui
utilisent le métro le bus se promener
dans paris est ce que j à paris voilà
bordeaux à des gens à toulouse ou à la
rue
donc s'il ya toute une série de
confession dans le domaine du transport
dans le domaine du tourisme des secteurs
entiers ou les choses mais difficile à
reprendre
certes on aura ni voyager serge pense
que les compagnies low cost grosjean
trafic ce que l'écran compagnies
aériennes devront leur clientèle
d'affaires est ce que le certains
modèles touristiques ne sont pas
déplacés qu'il faudra revoir
il va falloir vraiment inventé et il
faudra que l'état soit à la hauteur de
la situation et nous les collectivités
qu'elle oublie tout ça sur le terrain on
est certainement les lieux adaptés pour
trouver des réponses ici je devais à ce
moment précis de notre rencontre quelque
chose amour beaucoup de citoyens c'est
d'aller voter
c'est vrai que il ya encore du colis du
mois de juin
c'est vrai que les processus de vote
seront peut-être un peu plus long mais
la démocratie et qui font danger aussi à
cause de certaines forces politiques
extrémistes a besoin d'être confortés et
à les choisir ses conseillers
départementaux à les choisir la la
politique de solidarité de son
département c'est très important je vis
aussi pour nos collègues candidats aux
élections régionales
choisir sa région choisirait grands
investissements choisir les choix que de
billes les choix écologiques
c'est très important et on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé mais le département lille
est aussi en première ligne sur
l'écologie l'environnement avec nos
espaces naturels sensibles donc la
preuve
légende le paysage la lutte contre
l'excès des aumières que tu avais était
l'important c'est quelque chose sur
lequel il faut se mobiliser et on a
besoin que l'on citoyens aillent voter
pour qui 'les plus tôt alors dit à titre
personnel
les forces républicaines quelle qu'elle
soit tous ceux qui sont des modérés de
gauche droite ou d'ailleurs
mais en tout cas il est important que
ces élections ne soient pas passées par
pertes et profits parce que c'est un
moment important et démocratie et ça va
façonner aussi le paysage de notre pays
pour l'élection présidentielle donc
toute dernière question beaucoup plus
personnel dominique bussereau il n'y a
pas trop de vent ce moment il n'y a pas
de tempête parce que là il ya des
groupes qui sont barrées on se voit en
charente maritime et des mois que les
sonars et les hélicoptères et sécurité
civile et de la gendarmerie
essaye de survoler les pêcheurs ne se
perdent pas mais c'est un bon moment
pour venir découvrir dans une quête de b
toutes les zones touristiques françaises
sur les autres montent de montagne les
eaux du littoral les zones de ce qu'on
appelle l'arrière pays
il faut aussi aider nos professionnels
du tourisme
en attendant l'été à revivre et à
pouvoir tout simplement vivre d'exister
payer leur personnel et développer leurs
produits
voilà merci beaucoup de minutes
bussereau merci à françois sauvadet
merci à jean luc gleyze président du
département de la gironde président de
la côte d'or pour monsieur sauvadet pour
françois sauvadet et puis bien sûr au
président de l'assemblée des
départements de france
merci aux téléspectateurs nous avoir
suivi sur public sénat merci vous voir
jérôme fourquet pour tous ces éclairages
et cette étude et c'était une très
intéressante
je vous dis à très bientôt merci
beaucoup
[Musique]